PRESIDENT TRUMP SPARKING ANOTHER
MEDIA FIRESTORM.
CRITICS UP IN ARMS OVER A
"NEW YORK TIMES" REPORT ABOUT
THE PRESIDENT WARNING THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TO PROSECUTE
HILLARY CLINTON AS WELL AS
FORMER FBI DIRECTOR JAMES COMEY.
SOME IN THE MEDIA SOUNDING THE
ALARM ABOUT TRUMP'S INTENTION.
>> IT'S A DEFINING MOMENT IN THE
HISTORY OF THE DRUM PRESIDENCY.
THIS IS A DEMONSTRATION OF HIS
UNFITNESS TO BE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, OF HIS ABUSE OF
PRESIDENTIAL POWER, HIS EMBRACE
OF AUTHORITARIANISM.
>> THIS NEWS IS ON SCALE WAY
BEYOND ANYTHING ELSE WE'VE SEEN
IN LEGAL CONTROVERSIES WITH
DONALD TRUMP.
>> THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS IN
AUTHORITARIAN COUNTRIES.
THE PRESIDENT ORDERS, THE LEADER
ORDERS THE INVESTIGATION AND
PROSECUTION OF HIS POLITICAL
ENEMIES.
>> Juan: SUPPORTERS ARGUE THAT
TRUMP HAS BEEN SAYING THIS FOR A
LONG TIME, LIKE DURING THE
PRESIDENTIAL DEBATE TWO YEARS
AGO.
>> President Trump: >
>> President Trump: I
>> President Trump: F
>> President Trump: W
>> President Trump: N
>> President Trump: H
>> President Trump: M
>> President Trump: I
>> President Trump: G
>> President Trump: T
>> President Trump: O
INSTRUCT MY ATTORNEY GENERAL TO
GET A SPECIAL PROSECUTOR TO LOOK
INTO YOUR SITUATION BECAUSE
THERE HAS NEVER BEEN SO MANY
LIES, SO MUCH DECEPTION.
>> Juan: DANA, YOU HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE PEOPLE, LIKE
ALAN DERSHOWITZ TODAY ON STEVE'S
SHOW SAID YOU CAN DO THIS.
YOU DO NOT USE -- YOU DON'T USE
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM TO
PUNISH HER POLITICAL OPPONENTS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> Dana: YOU CAN SAY A LOT OF
THINGS INSIDE THE WHITE HOUSE.
YOU CAN SAY I WANT THIS TO
HAPPEN AND THEN YOU MIGHT HAVE A
GENERAL COUNSEL THAT IS WISE AND
SMART AND CLEVER LIKE DONALD
McGAHN WHO SAYS IT'S NOT A
GOOD IDEA, MR. PRESIDENT.
HIS LAWYER IS BILL BURKE.
FULL DISCLOSURE, HE IS A GOOD
FRIEND OF MINE.
HE SAYS DONALD McGAHN IS NOT
GOING TO COMMENT ON THE LEGAL
ADVICE TO GET TO THE PRESIDENT
BUT HE NOTED THAT THE PRESIDENT
NEVER TO HIS KNOWLEDGE ORDERED
ANYONE TO PROSECUTE
HILLARY CLINTON OR JAMES COMEY.
AGAIN IT'S LIKE HE MIGHT HAVE
BROUGHT IT UP AND MAY BE YOU'RE
FRUSTRATED, THEY ARE GOING TO
INVESTIGATE ME, INVESTIGATE HER.
SIR, WE CAN'T DO THAT.
OKAY, FINE.
THEN THEY MOVE ON.
WHEN THEY SAY THIS IS WHAT
HAPPENS IN A DICTATORSHIP, NO,
WHAT HAPPENS IN A DICTATORSHIP
OF THE PROSECUTION ACTUALLY
HAPPENS.
AND IT'S NOT A FAIR TRIAL.
THERE'S NO DUE PROCESS AND THAT
PERSON IS IMMEDIATELY THROWN IN
JAIL OR EXTRADITED.
THAT'S WHAT I WOULD SAY.
>> Juan: WHAT WOULD YOU SAY TO
PEOPLE WHO SAY WHY IS HE
DISCUSSING THIS AND THEN OTHER
SET ON THE TAPE THAT HE'S BEEN
SAYING THIS DURING THE CAMPAIGN.
HE WAS SAYING IF I'M PRESIDENT,
GOING TO GET A SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR BUT McGAHN AND
OTHERS TOLD HIM THIS COULD
RESULT IN YOUR IMPEACHMENT,
MR. PRESIDENT  .
>> Steve: THE CONVERSATION
THAT YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT WHERE
WE HAD ALAN DERSHOWITZ IN THE
STUDIO, HE SAID IT'S NOT
IMPEACHABLE BUT IT'S JUST DUMB.
HE SHOULD NOT HAVE DONE THAT.
BUT HE REALLY AMPED IT UP, THEN
CANDIDATE DONALD TRUMP BECAUSE
IT'S ONE THING FOR YOU TO SAY IT
WHEN YOU'RE ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL.
BUT THEN WHEN YOU ARE STANDING
RIGHT NEXT TO THE PERSON SAYING
IF I WIN, BIG TROUBLE!
THAT IS SOMETHING.
BUT THAT IS DONALD TRUMP.
>> Juan: IT SOUNDS LIKE
RHETORIC ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL
BUT WHEN YOU'RE ACTUALLY
PROPOSING IT, IT'S WHAT GETS
PEOPLE UP.
JEDEDIAH COMING FOR THESE CLAIMS
OF AUTHORITARIANISM MEANT SAYING
THAT THIS IS WORSE THAN SINCE
WATERGATE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
STEVE EIPPER YES RIDICULOUS.
I'M STILL TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT THE STORY IS.
HE DIDN'T PROSECUTE ANYBODY
ACTUALLY.
YOU HAVE HIS LEGAL
REPRESENTATION COMING OUT AND
SAYING YEAH, WE DIDN'T HEAR HIM
SAY HE WAS ACTUALLY GOING TO
PROSECUTE ANYBODY.
IT'S JUST SO INTERESTING THAT
NOW "THE NEW YORK TIMES" HAS
GONE FROM STORIES WITH ACTUALLY
THOUGHT THEY WERE GOING TO FIND
COLLUSION.
NOW THEY HAVE DECIDED WE DIDN'T
FIND THE CLUES AND WE ARE
LOOKING FOR SO NOW THEY ARE
WRITING OUTRAGEOUS STORIES ABOUT
THINGS HE MIGHT'VE SAID THAT
MIGHT'VE HAPPENED AND NOW
CABLE NEWS IS EXPLODING OVER
IT.
I DON'T SEE THE STORY.
HE DIDN'T PROSECUTE ANYBODY.
HE DIDN'T DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
IT'S NOT A STORY IF SOMEBODY
SAYS YEAH, I'M GOING TO DO THIS
AND THEN NOTHING ACTUALLY
HAPPENS.
WHAT ARE WE SUPPOSED TO BE UPSET
ABOUT?
>> Juan: EVEN IF YOU HAVE TO
RESTRAIN THE PRESIDENT.
>> Jedidiah: HOW DO YOU KNOW
THEY HAD TO RESTRAIN HIM?
>> Juan: DONALD McGAHN WROTE
A MEMO SO THE MEMO EXISTS.
>> Jedidiah: OKAY, BUT SOMEONE
SAYING IT'S NOT JUST BECAUSE --
HE WASN'T JUST SAYING THESE
THINGS BECAUSE THESE PEOPLE, FOR
EXAMPLE, COMEY, THESE ARE HIS
ADVERSARIES.
HE WAS SAYING IT BECAUSE HE WAS
CONCERNED ABOUT HILLARY CLINTON
AND BLEACHING A SERVER.
SAYING LISTEN I THINK THIS
SHOULD BE LOOKED INTO.
THAT WAS THE POINT THAT
RESONATED WITH EVERY AMERICAN
SITTING AT HOME SAYING WHAT
COMEY DID SEEMS UNREASONABLE.
IT WAS A SELLING POINT FOR HIM
TO SAY THIS DOESN'T LOOK RIGHT
HOW IT WENT DOWN AND I THINK IT
SHOULD BE LOOKED INTO.
THAT'S DIFFERENT FROM HIM
MANDATING PROSECUTING HIS
ENEMIES AND ACTUALLY FOLLOWING
THROUGH LIKE A DICTATOR.
HE'S NOT A DICTATOR.
NOTHING ABOUT THIS IS
DICTATORIAL.
>> Juan: GREG, WHAT DO YOU
MAKE OF THIS?
>> Greg: IF YOU TOOK EVERY
OUTRAGED THE MEDIA EMBRACED THAT
WAS BORN FROM TRUMP VENTING, YOU
WOULD HAVE NOTHING.
HIS VENTING IS TO DEFINED BY
THINKING OUT LOUD AND WONDERING
OF WHAT POSSIBILITIES OUT THERE
THAT COULD SOLVE SOMETHING THAT
BUGS HIM AND THEN SOMEBODY SAYS
SOMETHING HE SAYS OKAY.
THEN HE FINDS SOMETHING ELSE.
TRUMP IS A SALESMAN AND A
BUSINESSMAN AND WHAT YOU DO WHEN
YOU ENTER A NEW JOB?
YOU ASK A BUNCH OF QUESTIONS.
SOME ARE CREDIBLY STUPID AND
THAT'S WHY DONALD TRUMP IS
DIFFERENT THAN ANYBODY IN THE
MEDIA.
THE MEDIA IS TOO INSECURE TO ASK
STUPID QUESTIONS.
IT'S ALMOST A SUPERHERO POWER
TRUMP HAS.
HIS WILLINGNESS NOT TO FEEL
SHAME WHEN HE'S WRONG AND WHEN
HE ASKS A DUMB QUESTION.
CAN I PROSECUTOR?
YOU CAN'T PROSECUTE HER.
OKAY.
THERE IS THIS AMNESIA I READ
ABOUT WHERE YOU FORGET WHATEVER
IT IS THAT SAME DAY SO EVERY DAY
IS NEW.
THE MEDIA HAS TRUMP AMNESIA.
THEY WAKE UP EVERY DAY AS IF
IT'S THE FIRST DAY OF THE
PRESIDENCY AND THEY FREAK OUT.
I DON'T KNOW WHY HIS CRITICS ARE
SO FAT.
THEY ARE ALWAYS UP IN ARMS.
THEY SHOULD BE SO FIT.
SCREAMING.
THEY SHOULD BE ON THE COVER OF
MEN'S HEALTH.
INSTEAD THEY ARE JUST BLOATED.
HOW ARE THEY SO BLOATED WHEN
THEY ARE SCREAMING ALL THE TIME?
>> Dana: CAN I ADD ONE THING
ON THIS.
BARACK OBAMA CAMPAIGNED ON
CLOSING GITMO.
YOU REMEMBER THE OTHER STORY
THAT ON HIS FIRST DAY IN THE
OVAL OFFICE AFTER HE WAS SWORN
IN, SITTING AROUND AND HE'S LIKE
OKAY, WHERE'S THE PAPERWORK?
I'M GOING TO CLOSE GITMO.
AND THE STAFF SAYS SIR, YOU
ACTUALLY CAN'T DO THAT.
IT HAS TO GO THROUGH CONGRESS.
HE IS LIKE WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
YOU CAN'T DO IT BECAUSE THE LAW
SAYS.
THAT'S WHY YOU HAVE SMART PEOPLE
AROUND YOU WHO CAN ADVISE YOU ON
THINGS YOU MIGHT NOT NECESSARILY
KNOW ABOUT THAT ARE DETAILED IN
THE LAW.
>> Juan: GREG, RESPONDS TO
WHAT YOU SAID.
I THINK THE LIBERAL SIDE WOULD
SAY ARMY NORMALIZING WAS VERY
UNUSUAL BEHAVIOR?
THE PRESIDENT TRYING TO USE THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT OF
PUNISHMENT.
>> Greg: THE WORD NORMALIZING
SHOULD NOT BE MORE NORMALIZED.
I HATE THAT WORD.
THEY TRUMP AMNESIA, THE
PSYCHOLOGY IS THAT PEOPLE ARE
EXHAUSTED BY HIM.
SO HERE'S AN EXPERIMENT.
IF YOU ERASE TRUMP FROM TODAY,
YOU WOULD HAVE THE LARGEST
PEACETIME EXPANSION PROBABLY IN
HISTORY.
DRAMATIC DECLINES IN POVERTY AND
VIOLENCE WORLDWIDE.
THINGS ARE LOOKING PRETTY GOOD.
THERE'S A LOT OF PROSPERITY AND
FRESH IDEAS AND NEW TECHNOLOGY.
IT'S A SIMPLER BUT SOMEHOW
COMPLICATED LIFE WITH
TECHNOLOGY.
MY POINT IS DESPITE THIS THERE
IS A SENSE OF DOOM AROUND THE
CORNER.
EVERYONE THINKS SOMETHING AWFUL
IS HAPPENING EVEN THOUGH THE
PHYSICAL EVIDENCE IS TELLING YOU
THERE'S OPTIMISM EVERYWHERE AND
THE REASON IS IS BECAUSE ALL OF
THIS IS A PSYCHOLOGICAL PROBLEM.
IT CERTAINLY ISN'T A PHYSICAL
ONE.
>> Juan: ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
I GUESS THAT'S WHY HE HAS
THIRTYSOMETHING APPROVAL.
>> Greg: IS HIGHER THAN THAT.
YOU MISREPRESENTED THAT.
>> Juan: AND THEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYING IT'S A
NO-BRAINER WHO HE THINKS SHOULD
BE NAMED "TIME" MAGAZINE'S
PERSON OF THE YEAR.
>> President Trump: IT'S
CALLED PERSON OF THE YEAR,
RIGHT?
NO LONGER MAN OF THE YEAR,
I DON'T KNOW.
THAT'S UP TO "TIME" MAGAZINE.
I'VE BEEN THERE BEFORE.
I CAN'T IMAGINE ANYBODY ELSE
OTHER THAN TRUMP.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: EVEN YOU FIND THAT
FUNNY.
>> Juan: IS HE SERIOUS?
>> Jedidiah: I THINK HE IS
PARTIALLY SERIOUS.
I THINK THIS IS HOW HE IS.
PEOPLE WHO DON'T GET THAT STILL
JUST DON'T GET TRUMP.
THAT'S JUST HOW HE FEELS.
HE FEELS LIKE LISTEN, I'M THE
PRESIDENT.
I AM DOING A WHOLE BUNCH OF COOL
STUFF, I CAN BE MAN OF THE YEAR.
I DON'T THINK THEY ARE GOING TO
PICK HIM.
>> Steve: PERSON OF THE YEAR
OR MAN OF THE YEAR OR THING OF
THE YEAR.
I LOOKED UP AND APPARENTLY IT'S
THE GREATEST INFLUENCE ON THE
EVENTS OF THE YEAR.
WHO HAS INFLUENCED MORE THINGS?
>> Dana: MAYBE ON THE MERITS
IT WILL BE HIM.
BUT IT'S GOING TO BE PELOSI.
I THINK SHE'S GOING TO GET
PERSON OF THE YEAR.
THEY ARE AT 39 SEATS FLIPPED.
SHE'S GOING TO BE SPEAKER AGAIN.
IT'S NOT A MAN.
IT'S A WOMAN.
I AM TELLING YOU ON THE MERITS,
TRUMP MIGHT DESERVE IT BUT I AM
PUTTING MY MARKDOWN.
>> Greg: AND YOU ARE RARELY
WRONG ON THIS.
I THOUGHT WE WERE GOING TO TALK
ABOUT THE CORRESPONDENTS'
DINNER.
THERE IS ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
WHERE TRUMP MADE SOMETHING
BETTER.
THE DINNER HAS NOW RETURNED TO
ITS ROOTS WHICH IS ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF JOURNALISM.
AFTER DECADES OF CELEBRITY
WORSHIP, IT WAS THE CURSE OF THE
PRESS.
THE INSECURE AND HOMELY IN THE
MEDIA ALWAYS WANTING TO BE NEAR
THE COOL KIDS.
TRUMP CURED THEM OF THAT.
>> Steve: AND NOW THEY DON'T
HAVE A COMIC.
>> Dana: HE WILL BE THE
FUNNIEST SPEECH THEY'VE HAD.
>> Juan: IT WILL BE UPROARIOUS